you've heard the name before surf shark
what do they do vpn's virtual private
network it is pretty much everywhere
because it takes you everywhere but this
is the best one this is by far the best
one and it's not only because
of the great offer that they give you
which by the way is and i always have to
write this down because it sounds untrue
if you enter promo code geordi you get
off and three months free they're
basically giving away vpn you have a vpn
you have a vpn you have a vpn you know
my favorite bit about it go on you know
with other vpns you kind of need to sign
up for one thing one device
right this one all your devices anywhere
covered reuse it so
you're saying you could have it on this
this and this all of them all of them
nice and easy good for you uh if you
want to
jump on american netflix you can do that
yeah spanish
french you can do that you're going
abroad a lot of you lot you're going to
with betha
oh i want to keep in touch and see
what's getting shown on bbc while i'm
aware
get yourself on the vpn you can watch
anything i want to use the internet just
like in england
when we go away everything's in spanish
three days you've been out there and
you're already wanting to know what the
[__] been going on at home don't stag
off the customers though
because they're just like the people
that's all if you want to be like that
then just sign up what's that my love
you're 83 off in three months for free
just use code geordie it's not hard
use the link down there as well because
it sort of lets them know that we sent
you yeah that's the most important bit
it's kind of the
key to this using our stuff um down you
go
boom get on so hold it on there yeah
while you're down there
click on the click the link that's the
important bit yeah so
surfshark they sponsor true news and
they keep it coming and
enjoy it enjoy it and enjoy true news
yeah you're welcome
it's a good one surf shark it's a good
[Music]
one
[Applause]
whoever the [__] jake paul is he's
fighting a very famous fighter in
whoever the [__] tyrone woodley is these
two guys are going to clash heads and
butt fists at some points in the next
couple of months but before that
they're going to do a lot of talking
with robots the robot's back
the robot's back and that's probably the
best part of press conference isn't it
imagine if all the time
say something positive about yourself
and i'll be the robot i think i've got
great hair
and uh kind of handsome that's what this
robot does do you remember in the last
press conference when jake dedicated it
to
one of his trainers who had deceased as
some of you guys know uh my security
guard
passed away another robot was just sort
of in the background going
yeah man it's a bit strange isn't it you
did
ladies and gents tyrone
woodley sorry tyron tyron tyron tyron
tyrone it's not tyrone it's not because
tyrone would be with an e yeah but a lot
of people tend to say tyrone to
annoy him to trigger him it's like him
calling him like jackie paul
tyron woodley he once made a rap song
called i'll beat your ass
and now they're playing it much more
common in north america that sports
stars cross over into the rap game loads
of basketball players
loads of nfl players every now and again
they just go oh i've got a mixtape and
you're like i'm not interested
beat your ass in real life beat your ass
on tv
i'll beat your ass in real life i'll
beat your ass on tv he tried to start
the rap career while he was champion
right the second that happened he lost
four fights in a row so maybe just stop
with the music 961 in the ufc
making his boxing debut on august 29th
the chosen one is this man doing a
really bad impression of a man
on download internet it's embarrassing
this man a youtube social media star
who has all of a sudden turned himself
into a pugilistic puncher
he's known as the problem child
could you look any more like okay it
looks like he's giving a user
ladies and gents this is your captain
speaking we're about to hit some
turbulence
i'm sorry whenever i'm built up
genuinely this is
it's terrible and i thought with show
time things were gonna level up a bit
you think show time you go
show time you know this guy behind scene
goes
no time ladies and gents
he's awful this guy i like his jacket
it's a little big it's a bit like
they've had the jacket for the actual
guy who should have been doing this job
and then they've literally thrown it on
him and went yeah it kind of fits that's
why he's looking off to the side because
they're going
he keeps looking is that all right he's
the janitor
and he's locked out here they basically
went we'll try him off he's that guy who
went in
i mean like they see goodwill hunting
they thought what home could it do
sure enjoy by the problem
because you guys you know had a private
photo shoot
you know there was no media there as is
the nature of privacy
i'm here to watch jake paul and tyron
woodley
put on a show this guy's explaining the
nature of privacy what's happening is
i'm
my attention is actually being taken
away from what i was interested in by
problem presenting and i'm just
a problem presenter yeah but in that
private photo shoot
you guys had a chance to you know kind
of face off
look at one another generally what a
face off
this is sky this guy's unbelievable they
should pair him up with anthony joshua
aka
anthony joshua msg aka madison square
gardens
and in that photo shoot
you said during the face-off quote
quote he now reads this this is this guy
is so
[__] terrible it is doing my head in
the zone
showtime ufc any of you lot how was how
am i unemployed by you like
what do i have to do i cannot be worse
than this i don't have the jacket is
that what it is the jacket
and also you're really problematic to
work with this chocolate i saw it
deep in his soul that he knew this right
hand was going to crack him in his skull
you still stand by that no i've changed
my mind i'm actually losing the fight
now
the hell kind of question is that yeah
i've thought about it now i've seen him
of course he's quite a big guy
i think i'm gonna struggle here i
haven't done my research before and i've
just discovered tyron woodley a fighter
tyron let me ask you this
because you told the boxing scene you're
gonna knock jake out in three rounds
say a quote oh god why do you keep
quoting them back to themselves
see a quote they're gassing him up
you've got power
he's whole he ain't want to fight in a
million years who's quote
literally he's being so non-specific
about which person said what
you just don't know this guy is i mean
this the worst
moderator we've ever seen whoa shannon
briggs was worse
let's go champion f him up you still
stand by there
stop asking them if they stand by words
they've said neither of these men are
backing down they're literally being
painted
you're here to get sound bites out of
them that can be then used later in
trailers yeah you're supposed to be
asking them questions to get these out
with them you're literally saying the
words for them you [__] idiot i mean
look at my resume brilliant okay he's
transitioning out of fighting he's now
bringing the resume into the room s.a.t
score was pretty good here in your
resume
okay went off to be a fighter see that
didn't go so well you did get to a
champion at some point though but then
you started you put down here uh your
interests rapping yeah so
it's not really a hobby that we're
looking to employ but yeah we'll keep
you on file
so many people come up to me on a
day-to-day basis you gotta knock him the
[__] out
i'm like damn what this dude did to
everybody that that's the exact
pressure that's going to crack you on
fight night jake is really good at this
isn't he he plays it smart
you have never been in a fight like this
and you know the whole mma community
robbie
carlos guarantee i've never been to
don't know who the [__] those guys are
clever responds from jake but definitely
a lie yeah
yeah he knows who they are but in that
moment he can't acknowledge anything
that tyron is using to build his
credibility
right he's got to be like who are they
you know what i mean the reality is
when tyron woodley beat darren till in a
title fight that was the same year jake
paul started
learning how to box that shows the
progression of jake paul
in a short space of time yes tyron
woodley's on the decline a little bit
but is still a force to be reckoned with
let's see so
just to get serious for a second what
jake paul is attempting to do here all
right
yes tyron woodley is a slightly smaller
man but the fact that the matter is he's
been
fighting so much longer and obviously
yes it's going to be pure boxing whereas
tyron woody comes from mma but this
would be a monumental achievement for a
youtuber
in a few years to take on a guy who when
he started was the champion of the world
mendel's this is a more dangerous fight
without doubt than what floyd mayweather
was for logan paul because the power
tyron woodley has in his hands is
serious that
it's a good shot and it's good night and
you're a meme when you lost to all of
those guys you had built-in excuses
oh they were the best what happens when
you lose whatever there's a good point
by jake in that
when tyron woodley was losing those
high-level ufc fights he could literally
say
i'm getting beat by top five in the
world individuals there's
nothing to be ashamed of whereas to lose
to jake paul it's a different kind of
pressure but did he
mentally your credibility is going to
take a hell of a knock
right now tyrone woodley is looked upon
by many
as top three welterweights of all time
by the way
in mma if he then goes and loses the
jake paul people are just not going to
look at him the same way ever again
tyron you know one of the things we saw
on social media
is that you show some pictures of you
training with floyd mayweather
um can you tell us how those sessions
went you've trained with floyd
mayweather yeah horrible actually i was
feeling a bit underweather that day so i
didn't pick up much stuff while i was in
the gym what do you expect him to say
from here
um can you tell us how those sessions
went
and did he give you maybe some some
tricks
some tricks well i just sort of took
them up juggling yeah i'm going to
basically get down do 10 press-ups yeah
yeah i'm actually going to juggle the
gloves
put them back on the hands and then
knock him out you're bouncing around
coaches like you do baby mamas how many
kids you got now
this is going well you're getting nine
year old man who's poor guess what
weak he looks like a fertile guy you
bought a used bentley
that's a really good disc there's
nothing wrong with a used bentley all
right first stop
okay i've i've had one we also know
they're also [__] expensive so
you want a new bentley believe me those
will white piano you want to use one
still white it's a lot like a beautiful
woman
it really doesn't matter who had it
first and who's got it now [__]
you know what i'm saying i don't know if
i concur you on your instagram
you're not a huge bentley flex is like
you might
use bentley he has the problem tyron
woodley
is playing the jake paul game when you
do that it's jake paul's game so he's
gonna win yeah what tyron should have
done is try to
old man him big brother and be like i'm
not here to [__] around with you
you know i'm gonna kick the [__] out of
you and be done with it that's what he
should have been but
he he's fighting fire with fire and this
is what jake does it's to a point now
where and this is a known thing
conor mcgregor has even been copying
jake paul's stuff a lot of people
originally called jake a conor mcgregor
copycat
right but now the whole your girl is in
my dm
it's like all of this sort of type of
[__] con has been coming out with it's
straight up with the jake paul playbook
i know people probably won't like hear
that but
a lot of people have noticed it it ain't
just me it's common knowledge now
18 months ago when i said i wanted to
fight conor people laughed at me
now i'm laughing at conor with a broken
ankle sitting there
in the octagon and he needs jake paul
more than
more than i need him on the one hand
conor mcgregor's last pay-per-view just
did 1.8 million buys which is
the second in ufc history only to his
fight with khabib which is number one
conor's still selling way more
pay-per-views than any other fighter out
there
you know floyd's last fight definitely
didn't do 1.8 million with logan
connor's number one it's selling
pay-per-views right now
however conor's next fight allegedly
against dust emporia probably wouldn't
do that kind of business because
most people feel like they've got their
conclusion from that trilogy whereas
jake paul and conor mcgregor hyping a
fight up
would be mayhem they'd probably do two
million pay-per-view buys
in a sense connor and jake would do
great business together
doesn't mean either of them need each
other though right but i like where he's
going with this yeah i see what you're
saying
speaking of conor mcgregor just to
quickly skip over to this jake had a
chain made of conor mcgregor
sleeping he's got nyquil in his hand
he's he's called it sleepy mcgregor
hundred grand despite this this cost a
hundred grand
that it's got diamonds on the puns hey
mcgregor you better win tonight
otherwise your career is over and if you
lose
that 50 million dollar bet i gave you
won't be on the table anymore so don't
choke like you normally do
sleepy mcgregor don't go night night
nyquil mcgregor
[__] [__] as we know now mcgregor
did lose the fight and jake then offered
the train
as a gift to justin poirier who accepted
jake then replied do you want me to snap
the leg off or do you want to do it
yourself wow
okay and then i think dustin's going to
auction it off for his charity right
that's a good idea yeah so in a way
as much as it's probably annoying the
hell out of mcgregor it's making money
for the people who need it i was going
to say do you expect there may be one
and possibly two
paul brothers ringside also cage side i
couldn't care about them until dingbats
do you
so there's no you don't see any future
where you box either of those two
i don't i don't see so but you know
never say never you know i mean if
they're going to keep competing and
whatnot
who knows but dingbats to tell them what
i like about mcgregor there is he's on
an aussie show
and he's using terminology that they'd
be familiar with right smart yeah people
from all walks of life you can
talk to anyone prince or pauper yeah
dingbat when a dingo
made it with a bat right dingba covid we
are taking
you very seriously but anything that you
bring to the ring it just won't matter
three rounds i think we're going to see
a lot more of jake's game and how he
actually boxes because pretty much
the last few fights has just been him
laying people out pretty quick
whereas tyron's gonna have a lot of
speed a lot of explosive power
and it's not gonna be just as simple as
throw the one two and watch the guy go
down
but i think jake paul's power is highly
underestimated
when you watch how he throws for his
weight class i think he hits a lot
harder than what he should do
and with tyron being a smaller guy i
don't know if he'll be able to take that
kind of power
if i beat you you have to get i love
jake paul tattooed on you but but if you
beat me i get i love tyrone woodley
tattooed on me and you have to post it
on your instagram feed
dealer no deal deal or no deal
can we shake on it one thing mcgregor
did early on
which he has sort of lost his way of
doing is
ramping the pressure up on his opponent
no matter what little things he can get
his opponent
to agree to to feel like this is bigger
than what
i'm used to to feel the pressure it's
not about the tattoo it's jake trying to
go the stakes are higher the higher
as high as possible because he knows he
is going to be fine with that he doesn't
feel the way a normal person feels under
pressure
because he's grown up around cameras and
this is his way of just
getting so much pressure on tyron
woodley he caves he goes along with it
what he should have said was
you're a little [__] boy and i ain't
getting [__] tired it was like this
[__] i'm just gonna knock you out
but he he plays the game because he
doesn't want to be seen to be a bottle
job but it's
that's the problem you're being childish
yeah you don't realize
he's luring him in you can't old man
someone when you're agreeing to get
matching tattoos right yeah yeah which
they actually should do i think that's
nice you should just get each other's
sort of name on
anyway on the ring finger the rings are
lovely that'll be really nice
imagine just towards the end when
they're really sweaty and covered in
each other's blood and then all of a
sudden
they go to cuddle and embrace
gorgeous love that moment someone else
who's transitioned from social media to
fighting this week and done it very very
successfully
addison ray we all know who that is
we we don't we don't know who i've heard
the name i thought that i thought they
did cars does she not like used to uh
[__] some of those big name youtubers i
think she's got her own career thank you
very much brian
five million subs hey uh it's addison
right back with another youtube video
i get the point now she's just you know
your everyday youtuber girl but
then she got a gig with ufc i studied
broadcast journalism in college for
three whole months
to prepare for this moment she studied
hard for three months
she was so good they gave her the whole
degree in three months that should have
taken her five years did they keep
borrowed to do sucker i don't think they
kept
didn't go away oh oh they got rid of her
oh they got rid
it's fair to say though that three
months did not prepare her well because
ufc
didn't even release some of the footage
however someone else did get footage of
her interviewing dustin poirier most
excited
to go get a win moving forward
awesome that's amazing i know when i'm
at a fight i want
i want joe rogan post fight to go
awesome that's amazing
i actually feel sorry for her now she's
been sacked for doing what she was
brought in to do she was
brought in to look pretty to ask
questions she's doing both of those
right now
her answer to the question is not great
that's amazing that's what who she is
like in fighting entertainment they're
many companies the zones sky sports
ufc have a select few women who
clearly aren't lifelong fight fans
who were brought in to offer something
else to the broadcast and
sometimes you need a presenter who was
more of a
an overall sports presenter rather than
the the fight analyst not everyone on
a on a broadcast has to be a
professional fight analyst because
that's why you've got
pro fighters there like us i i feel like
you know
it's a bit harsh on her just because
she's a youtuber like maybe they got
this wrong
yeah i i do but she's just been a bit
humiliated for being
what she is yeah and that's sad that's
the problem though brian that's the
cocktail of things so the cocktail of
things is the money she will have
received for this
the fact that she then bragged about not
having the qualifications sort of
rubbing it in other people's
ways this is the thing 99 of people who
present have not got journalist
qualifications but there are people out
there who've put in the work despite not
having qualifications from a university
to learn how to be a journalist they
don't look like that they don't look
like that and let's be honest looking
good on camera
is part of the job which is probably why
i have not been hired yet i must admit i
don't love the dress
i think the dress could have been a
better color i think yellow would have
been better on her for a start or yeah
it would have brought your cheeks out
all right or
well i talked yeah
the weekend didn't get much better for
her because good friend
of the ufc he's a good friend of dnry
actually yes and
uh in many people's hearts still the
american president donald trump
popped by here's addison ray introducing
herself as if she's five
that is a weird one isn't it so nice to
meet you donald trump are you okay
addison
she's just harmless isn't she though
what would you do if you saw an
ex-american president
at the ufc probably punch them and say
stop killing kids abroad
okay so let's just take you through a
quick timeline of racism here in the uk
yeah that's right it still exists in
2021 within these shores as much as
there are some people who tried to deny
it ultimately don't worry no one's
calling you a racist unless you are a
racist at which point i'm calling you a
racist
there was a lot of racist backlash
against a couple of the england guys
well uh three of the england players
missed penalties and they
happen to be black and of course
[__]
will put that down to their skin color
and
use it against them so a marcus rashford
a man who has done
an insanely good amount for this country
as a young footballer whose
responsibility it is solely
to score goals for manchester united
felt like
he needed to get involved with the
community to help the children get you
know free school meals and all that
just an all-around great guy platform
yeah um
the right absolutely he's he he's a
councillor state hero to me
come good uh and um you know there's a
mural of him which was defaced
in manchester the community had turned
out and
went over what was written with loads of
messages
of goodwill to mark this and loads of
thank you and support for him which is
lovely and it just shows that you know
the tiny minority of of [__] who think
that
that sort of attitude is all right will
be overcome
by the good or not even good just decent
proper you know it shouldn't even be
considered good to not be racist it
should just be considered normal
what we're seeing was a lot of day
drinking which then made a lot of
racists feel
very comfortable there was videos going
out there was tweets going out so many
a lot of them have been exposed and i'm
glad but at the same time
it's awful these black players had to
read and say some of those things and
feel the way
it made them feel and of all people
at the start of the tournament when the
players wanted support
for what they were doing as a gesture to
stand against
racism they got no support from boris
johnson but now it's trendy
now people are seeing these black
players as victims
who wants to be the superman boris
johnson boris johnson
you've come in to save people again
you've really got your timing down again
boris thanks
well done boris you've clearly learned
your lessons from the past the same guy
in the past who
referenced watermelon smiles and
pikaninis in some of his own articles
when referring to black people and not
long ago he called muslim women who wear
a certain garment which covers
all of their face bank robbers and post
boxes
oh that's awkward because i don't think
boris based on your record
you're gonna be able to go to the game
soon you and your ministers have stoked
division over football has taken the
knee saying it was just gesture politics
saying it was fans choice to boo the
team
and going back there is further evidence
of this divisive politics and language
from you be it
describing muslim women in veils as
letterboxes or bank robbers or indeed
african people as picking nannies with
watermelon smiles
do you know when like you're getting a
dressing down from your parents and you
sort of you're looking down and you're
like and
he's sort of acting as if nothing's
happening did i say that yeah
like to be a a leader not even a good
leader acknowledging
where you've gone wrong is like abc you
know what i mean very basic
extremely clear the way he's just being
childish and sort of
just must just
for many people your own record
personally undermines your image as a
unifying prime minister
what are you going to do to change that
well thanks
beth obviously i uh you know i reject
that
doesn't matter if you reject it you have
said some stupid [__] in the past next
time you have an argument with your
partner and they go
you did go out all night and get drunk
you came home you threw up on the carpet
and you came
into bed and you threw up there as well
this is exactly what happened
well no i reject that well you can
reject it all you want boris is [__]
true
but we've got to go further we're going
to use the online
harms bill to ensure that the the big
internet
uh companies the uh the social media
platforms
uh that uh allow uh race hate facebook
and twitter and snapchat and
instagram i love that all the races are
like but he didn't say tick tocks yeah
exactly
i'm off to that i'll be dancing while
calling everyone the n-word
champion that's unbelievable yeah at the
same time said it was all right yeah
he didn't say a tick-tock that's a good
point yeah he didn't or youtube
one of the weirdest titles you've ever
shown me british youtuber
becomes korean via surgery absolutely
now i'm not one to judge so i'm just
gonna open-mindedly
accept what he says this is british
youtuber i get the feeling i might be
upsetting him there olly london a
classically
korean name something that's been like
on my mind for a long time
and i've been very confused about how i
identify i've been very very confused
and you know i've seen a lot of other
people online that have come out
and been very brave about it the lgbt
community is crying out for this
what the [__] is going on well this
guy's coming out i think he's gay and
shared their story about how they
identify
their gender their pronouns etcetera so
absolutely
yeah gender is very difficult to
identify right now
no come on now brian don't be
close-minded towards someone
who identifies as well he's going to be
one of them my pronouns are they
them korean jimin because i know a lot
of people don't understand me but i do
identify as korean i'm sorry you what
sorry you
identify as what you know i've taken
courage from these incredibly brave
um people and it is pride month at the
moment so you know i thought this was
the best time to do it
korean pride it's korean pride month
we've always said it we've always
thought it and i do look korean now
i do feel korean i do look great
i love that that's my favorite bit of
the whole video that's the best bit of
the video so far i look korean now
why got the eyes i don't identify as
british so
please don't refer to me any media or
anyone online as british see i told you
i would have upset him there i said
british youtuber at the beginning
you've dead nationality um yeah that's
so true
because i i identify as korean that's
just my culture that's my home country
yeah i've just adopted that culture and
that i've just decided
i'm just korean now this is the thing
right you know back in the day when i
first discovered like rap music and and
i'd hear them like rapping and about
they were from compton right there'd be
a little bit of me about it that'd be
cool
i've struggled as well at some point it
would be cool to be from compton
but i'm not i'm from newcastle yes and
i've got to accept that yeah because
that
is reality that's exactly how i look now
he keeps telling us
that's exactly how i look if there's
there's one thing i like to do is just
to tell people
how i look so that even though they can
see me i need to let them know what
they're looking for
exactly you know what i mean look at the
eyes korean this guy is
like it's like driving around in the
course of me and like
it might have corsa on it but it
identifies as a lambo my two bed
semi-detached
actually now identifies as a mansion
i've finally had the courage i've
undergone my um racial
uh i can't think of the word
transitional surgery
i'm picking up english this is so true i
i do appreciate that he's talking so
much [__] that even he can't even fathom
what the [__] has gone through my racial
whatever uh surgery
and as you'll observe i'm now korean and
correct me in the comments if i'm wrong
there's more to being korean than
getting your eyes done oh absolutely not
brian
no you know it's like one of my pals
getting a ton because he works on a
building site and going yeah i'm spanish
now
this is romanuel this is the thing
though right with this guy
he's had 18 plastic surgeries none of
them seemingly successful
his nose has crumbled to bits like he's
fought young to be having a facelift so
it looks ridiculous none of these bits
match it looks like someone's playing
mr potato head and on the off chance he
sees this i
urge him to seek serious mental health
um help because there is a clear
addiction to plastic surgery going on
for a start
let alone when you're coming out with
nonsensical ideas like being
transracial or whatever else who is
around you when you go in for
i don't know let's say your third or
fourth surgery that is clearly
not necessary at such a young age surely
someone has to put his hand
on them look stop what you're doing 18.
i get it you like
korean culture but you're fun be a fan
exactly listen to dr
dre if you want to you know embrace the
culture of you know california yeah
you're fun if you want to go there visit
get yourself across
you don't all of a sudden start having
surgery to make yourself
look like dr dre yeah and not only that
you don't go
hey we've all had the same experience
here am i right homies
yeah exactly because when you come from
what
it's it's just weird and i finally have
the korean look so i'm actually really
happy
you look at these korean people right
right some some attractive looking
people you know
good handsome men pretty women all of
that good stuff
and then him down the bottom here you
can see him he's right there
he is do you know how i could point them
out immediately because he looks nothing
like them
yeah surely if i'm korean i'm offended
by this he's walking into a room of
korean people and they've gone
all right man ah you're right good to
see you ali goes jimin
got the eyes and they go you got the
walls hurry this is mental
well that's the thing they have had him
on this morning and i believe
of course is there anything this morning
will not prostitute for views by the way
ollie london who identifies as
non-binary
says they've secretly spent many years
feeling trapped in the wrong body he's
very smart because what he's done is
he's wrapped up the non-binary thing
with the korean thing what he's trying
to do is hide behind
how sensitive people are around being
non-binary correct you know
and being misgendered and all of this
sort of stuff and attached being korean
to that as well
yeah they're not the same thing no i can
think it's absolutely
fair that you don't feel like a male or
female but think it's
mental that you think you're korean
that's absolutely doable
you're not going to get me on that one
right but he's not gonna get me on that
he did try
well last month the british born social
media star underwent what ollie has
called racial
transition surgery and announcements
notice how phil goes what ollie is
called
what we call bollocks this is him
linking to the audience going we've got
another freak on
this will be a laugh for you i
understand the hypocrisy that we're
covering this
but at the same time we've not invited
the guy over to basically point and
laugh at him well this has prompted
quite a big reaction around the world
and ollie joins us now to tell us more
ollie welcome it's lovely to see you
this morning thank you as you see the
surgery
he's not going to do the harm gesture
don't do he
done the hand gesture did the hand
gesture he did the hands everyone
he's done the korean hands as he knows
he's basically a little too into k-pop
that's what happened here
he got two into k-pop and thought i want
to be one of them
genuinely i am getting so much uh don't
[__] with cats yeah
like are you getting those vibes i i
feel a bit more sorry for this
he really reminds me of look at
mcnaughton it's like so bad
he's got those vibes hasn't he yeah if
this man invites you around to his hotel
room just
busy don't go even self-isolating yeah
covered make any excuse up this man
will [__] your corpse
[Music]
i know when i feel a bit korean there's
just times where
i think that myself like like i see my
life flash before my eyes right
and like i've gone from being on the job
site offshore and then all of a sudden
i'm watching this [__] with all of
these sad bacon dancers
and this is now my job and it sort of
makes me realize like what the [__]
happened
i watch this [__] weird [__] as a
job
here's the thing you're a diver that now
identifies as a youtuber
i have good news brian a fan of yours
and a fellow podcaster has a message
i remember anthony well true georgie's
one of my favorite
youtubers and he's a youtuber
that really inspired me i'm very
grateful for the kind words
however it looks like he's made one
about you and mark goldbridge beforehand
which
does sort of it dampens the message
doesn't dampen any no no
it does because i want to be the only
one and if if he's talking about
everyone else and saying oh
they're great too is it really that
special well i'm going to be honest i
also delete those well no well no
no need to delete them i i would say
though anthony it is disappointing for
brian when
his episode got 50 and mine got a
massive 62 views
beat you on the views beat you on the
views
thank you anthony for your kind words
i'll listen to the whole message
as will he i'm never gonna strike off
lawrence
unless he's gonna like to be complete
wrong
well that's completely wrong to be fair
he's covered himself there i do
appreciate that
you can never be too careful no need to
do the caveat
that means he's got a suspicion that i
might be a wronger well i don't well
what the chance of this being a wrong
one that's what i'm saying though with
your
little one little what the bdi's it's
the bdi
you can always speedy eyes you can
always tell unbelief that's what they
say with the
if you turn that to be one of them
but we all know he won't be the best
thing is he catches himself
because he realizes if i play out this
situation
one of what that is pedo is that what he
said i guess so
my favorite bit about it is you actually
see his eyes realize i've gone the wrong
way with this
if you turn that to me one and then
he's actually he goes oh no but we all
know he won't be
do we so you're never gonna hear me
psycho florence
or the true geordie dream because i
could have changed my life for the
better
anthony we really appreciate that cheers
anthony um we love you bro you've also
changed our lives for better
and um
he knows what i mean he's just pissed
off because you did a clip about me
before you did the clip
i only got more views yeah i did get
more views um he's actually doing
did he do a ufc there i don't want to
hear about his ankle break
because even before then justin fourier
was dominating him on the ground you do
not see the grinder
tell you what we've got our newest ufc
analyst i dread to think what the
comments will be like because
i've done the homework done the
groundwork tried for a long time at this
they give me a hard time bro so if they
say to you oh
he's not allowed to talk about the ufc
because he's never been a ufc fighter
before
we'll see if they'll see that yeah we'll
see if they'll see that anyone if
anything you think i'm going to get in
the comments and say that because
you get that let's see how good he was
doing it
let's see what anthony would do and the
problem is right
anthony just spewing his views out yeah
yeah he's never been in the octagon he's
never even
referee is he even allowed to talk about
the ufc
what if i shouldn't be alone the thing
that sickens me is what casually is he
just sits back and just goes
oh yeah i think i'll just i'll have a
view now oh he's just copying you
get in the cage anthony and then you can
talk about the ufc
right yeah win a title ufc ultimate
fighting
champions we've got a lot of love for
anthony so do check this channel out um
it is just anthony people over
complicate things last people
overcomplicate them and uh credit room
he's done a breakdown of
the ufc fight i will be checking that
out in full after we finish recording
this yeah i think this has been
another great episode of true news they
love it even if they do say so
themselves
thanks a lot to our sponsors sir shark
really appreciate you guys head over to
the link in the description go check
them out because it helps us
make true news goodbye